I
the Entrepreneurship is one of the
premier creators of jobs small
businesses create jobs
the Entrepreneurship clinic is designed
to represent low and moderate income
entrepreneurs in expanding or even
starting a new business they have the
entrepreneurial spirit they don't always
have the knowledge that it takes to get
through legally and that's what we're
here for but by and large they are here
to take something that they're
passionate about or something very
skilled at and turn it into a viable
living we've worked with such a great
variety of different businesses we've
had hair stylists pet sitters dog
walkers bakers carers people running
internet businesses for the standard
client that wants to come in and start a
business at the very least they're going
to be faced with regulations at the
local and state level the local level
they'll need to get a city business
license here in city of San Diego if
they're operating a home business that's
a separate permit they'll of course have
local taxes to pay they'll have to get a
DBA if they're not operating under their
name there may be other permits that are
required by the city depending on the
type of business it could be inspection
requirements if it has anything to do
with health or food then you're going to
have the county officials coming with
the right to inspect at the state level
of course there are state taxes if there
are any employees you'll have workers
comp to deal with you'll have believer
codes to deal with you'll have
unemployment insurance disability
insurance corporate taxes or entity
taxes I could go on one of the most
heartbreaking stories for me during my
time here his was a we had a client who
had been trained as a cosmetologist and
had worked in salons for a while and
just wasn't really interested in working
for someone else but she couldn't afford
to run her own salon so she came up with
this idea which I thought was brilliant
where she would she would be a mobile
hairdresser she and she primarily wanted
to go to senior homes or senior citizens
there they can't get out they can't get
to their hairdresser and she was going
to do their hair well it turns out that
in the state of California you can only
do hair or pay in a licensed
establishment and these senior homes
were not licensed establishments they
hadn't gone through the hoops necessary
to become licensed establishments and so
this was a business that I think would
have served a lot of consumers a
population that you know there are a lot
of people that still want to get their
hair done well into their 80s and it was
thwarted I mean there was no way that
she was going to be able to do this in a
legal manner and what that meant was not
only that she couldn't do it and this
was a livelihood she couldn't have she
couldn't employ anyone to help her do it
she wouldn't be able to get any
financing if she was able to if she
tried to do it underground it was
basically a you know a business that
never was it's really frustrating to to
work with a client who is really
passionate about their business who
needs to support a family but is faced
with all of these obstacles the business
permits and the licenses and the taxes
and the employment compliance and all of
that it's very frustrating for me to see
and to know what they have ahead of them
because this is something they're
starting the business of something at
the really passionate about one of the
best ways for the state of California to
get back on track financially i think is
to allow businesses to operate and and
operate without all the compliance and
regulatory burdens that they've been
having to suffer under basically the
state needs to lower taxes and decrease
the regulations